Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this season
of Arrow has been so awesome that I wanted
to celebrate the last four weeks before the
finale with a special countdown series.
This video will be my Top 10 Team Arrow Moments,
my favorite moments when it’s just them
in the Arrow Cave.
And I’m mostly just taking from Season 2.
Obviously this won’t include any potential
stuff from the finale, but I’ll be doing
a bunch of separate stuff when that comes.
I’ll be doing one of these every Wednesday
Morning until the finale airs.
That’s four weeks basically.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
feel free to suggest stuff for those other
bonus videos in the comments.
So here we go, careful for spoilers for everything
up to Episode 19 if you’re not caught up.
Number 10 - Team Arrow Compares Scars (ep14)
So this is just one of many Clock King Moments,
which I think is all around one of the best
Team Arrow Episodes this season.
It’s awesome to watch them train, but then
it breaks into them trying to one-up each
other with all their scars.
While they’re shirtless.
You’ve got grenade wounds, shotguns, it
goes on and on.
I think Oliver really won, but then the camera
pans over to Felicity and she pulls her tongue
out.
It’s this really fun moment of horror comedy.
It’s like saying all those scars they have
are something that brings them closer together,
even Felicity biting through her tongue.
If you were to walk in on them in that moment
out of context it would be pretty horrifying,
but to each of them it’s just a fun moment
to bond and show off.
It also did a good job of tee-ing up several
amazing Felicity based moments that also made
my list.
Number 9 - Oliver’s Psycho Ex GF (ep17)
The show is called Arrow, but we don’t spend
a lot of time in Oliver’s head.
Making this a rare moment where every including
the audience got to laugh at his expense.
They’re just shining a light on Oliver’s
troubled history with women.
Without being too mean.
I mean how often do you see a current girlfriend
laugh about their boyfriend’s ex?
Sara is a real trooper, I don’t think a
real person would be so quick to smile about
that situation.
From a writing stand point the producers even
commented on Oliver and his quote unquote
women this season.
Everyone always asks them when Olicity is
going to become a real thing, but at the beginning
of the season they said that Oliver would
continue to have chemistry with several women.
The new ones this season have been Sara and
Isabel.
Moira said Oliver is a terrible judge of character
and in the context she said it, I think she
was implying that women are a huge weakness
for him.
Like father like son.
Number 8 - Roy and Sin Extracurricular Mission
(ep11)
One of the rare B team moments to make the
list but one of the best.
Roy and Sin True Detective Season 2.
They take in on themselves to fight some crime
in the Glades, Sin has some amazing cos-play
and even though it ended up getting a little
scary for both of them, they had so much chemistry
that I really want to see more stuff like
this.
We don’t really know what’s going to happen
to either Roy or Sin before the finale or
if they’ll survive to season 3, but let’s
all cross our fingers that we get some more
young justice.
Number 7 - Slade In The Arrow Cave (ep19)
One of the best action scenes this season.
Arrow has some of the best fight choreography
thanks to stunt coordinator James Bamford
and everyone is great, but Stephen Amell and
Manu look like they don’t hold anything
back.
It’s just this ballet of parkour and broken
glass.
With the exception of Slade’s really appropriate
“Welcome Home” line, it could almost have
been a really cool silent film.
It’s scenes like this that make me wonder
why people don’t make more jokes about a
Slade Oliver ‘ship.
I’d argue that his history with Slade is
every bit as personal as his history with
Felicity, a la Olicity ‘shipping.
In reality, they’re like brothers who are
just at war in the biblical sense.
Like Cain and Abel.
Which kind of makes me think of the Winchesters.
Number 6 - You’re My Partner (ep10 36m)
This is pretty self explanatory, Oliver literally
tells Felicity how much he needs her and why
she’s so important to him.
It’s right after she’s been away visiting
Barry in Central City for a couple weeks.
And you can tell that without her around,
he’s starting to fall apart.
It’s a really good example of how she is
probably the most important member of the
Team.
Because Oliver would turn into a weepy pile
of flesh without someone to give him some
clarity and the occassional hug.
Number 5 - Roy Joins Team Arrow (ep 12)
Roy kind of falls into Team Arrow because
of the mirakuru drama.
I think even if he hadn’t gotten injected
Oliver would have eventually brought him into
the cave.
He’d already been doing more and more as
his informant, the mirakuru just kind of accelerated
the Roy Harper Arsenal storyline to warp speed.
It’s such a special thing when new people
join the family, so I really hope he stays.
As in, he survives to Season 3.
The producers have said that the Dark Knight
Trilogy is one of their guiding lights on
the series, so I always wonder if they’ll
do the Arrow version of Death in the Family.
The comic story where the Joker killed the
Jason Todd Robin.
Who later was ressurected as the Red Hood.
I know a lot of you keep asking me if Red
Hood will guest star on the show.
Number 4 - Felicity Training Scene (ep 14)
Anothe Clock King Episode moment, this was
one of the ways Felicity took a stand after
feeling like she got left out of that battle
wounds contest.
It is at the same time, the most adorable
and fun moments for her character this season.
It was also a bit of an intense point in her
relationship with Sara.
I think they’ve found some common ground
since then, but I always get the sense that
Felicity is watching her really closely.
Like the way Oliver’s mother was watching
Isabel Rochev.
I think if Sara ever did anything to hurt
Oliver Felicity would probably just explode
on her in tornado of fingernails and teeth.
I’ll let the tumblr fan fiction take that
story and run with it.
Number 3 - Barry Oliver Arrow Cave (ep8-9)
Also one of the funniest Team Arrow moments
all season.
It’s really a moment that stretches across
both of Barry’s episodes.
First, they abduct him into the Cave.
I’d like to believe Felicity shot him, but
I think we know it was Diggle.
Then watching him fanboy all over Oliver when
he learns he’s the Arrow.
And Oliver’s reaction to it all.
Oliver as opposed to Stephen Amell in real
life, is not a patient man.
Stephen Amell the actor takes a lot of his
personal time to interact with fans on facebook
and at conventions.
Oliver on the other hand barely tolerates
it.
Quick Question, do you think that he secretly
enjoys it when people fanboy and fangirl over
him?
Oliver that is, not Stephen.
Number 2 - Team Arrow Confronts Slade In The
Queen House (ep15)
The shit hits the fan and everyones blood
starts to boil.
The camera kind of zooms in on the action
when they all converge on Slade.
So as you’re watching on your TV you scoot
in closer really quick.
I really loved Slade’s reaction, I wonder
what crossed his mind in that moment.
He was definitely crunching the numbers on
what it would take to kill them all.
But I’ll bet evil tinkerbell Shado told
him to stop.
We didn’t really learn about her whispering
to him till episode 18.
She kind of informs all of his behavior.
and my Number 1 Team Arrow Moment - Oliver
Kills Count Vertigo To Save Felicity (ep7)
They don’t linger on it too much, but if
you remember, Oliver vowed not to kill anyone
this year.
That line plays in the intro to each episode
this season.
“I can’t be the killer I once was”.
So essentially he’s breaking his first commandment
by killing the Count.
And he didn’t even hesitate.
If you had any doubts about who the most important
person in Oliver’s life was, I think this
is the answer.
So just imagine what he would do if Slade
put Felicity in a similar situation.
He’d kill every single one of those Mirakuru
soldiers to save her.
I think the actual solution to getting rid
of Slade is going to be much more complicated
and won’t involve killing him.
But this Count Vertigo moment is the perfect
example of how far Oliver would go to protect
the people he cares about.
Felicity being at the top of the list.
So here’s a couple of my other favorites
that I had to leave off the list to keep it
from going on forever but, Felicity On Drugs
(ep14) Felicity and Oliver at the Rally (ep13),
Felicity Slapping Oliver Figuratively To Save
Thea (ep18), that first time Oliver came back
to the Arrow Cave and everyone had been watching
Sara do Salmon Ladders for hours (ep 13) and
Felicity takes point on the Clock King mission
and the time they used Felicity as bait to
catch the Dollmaker (ep3).
And something that I think we all really want
to see in Season 3 is Oliver actually training
Felicity to fight like he’s training Roy.
Maybe if everyone burns one of their genie
wishes we’ll get to see that in season 3.
But let me know what your favorite Team Arrow
moment has been this season and what kind
of moments with them all together do you want
to see that haven’t happened yet?
So tonight’s episode is going to be a huge
deal, make sure you watch it, I’ll be posting
my video right after the episode airs.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
And leave me suggestions for my next bonus
Arrow video.
I’m doing one for each of the remaining
episodes this season.
There’s only three more after tonight.
Right now click here for my Episode 20 video,
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
the video, and click here for my Q&A video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!